[Musik]
vergangenes jahr war nina neuer noch mit
manuel neuer zusammen auf mallorca jetzt
nach der trennung vom fußball
weltmeister macht sie urlaub mit
moderatorin victoria swarovski
die beiden verbringen ihre zeit auf
einer 27 meter lange luxusjacht vor
ibiza auf instagram sieht man dass sie
sowohl auf wasser als auch an land
mächtig spaß haben und die partysaison
trotz corona eröffnet haben
für alle die keine yacht haben noch zu
info in diesem jahr bleiben das pascha
und joshua und die restlichen klubs
geschlossen
deutlich weniger luxuriös machen gerade
sänger justin bieber und seine frau
hella urlaub denn die beiden machen
einen roadtrip durch den us bundesstaat
utah
das tat heute auf instagram romantisch
fotos von denen einige passend zur art
der reise im retrolook waren die
schnappschüsse zeigen die beiden schwer
verliebt oder haley beim chillen im pool
außerdem war das model ziemlich angetan
von diesem süßen pony letzte woche haben
wir von der 16-jährigen miriam berichtet
die sich bei edeka beworben hat und
aufgrund ihres kopftuches den job nicht
erhalten hat jetzt hat der edk konzern
konsequenzen gezogen und der marktleiter
hat seine zwei geschäfte in hamburg an
die genossenschaft abgegeben wie wichtig
werte sind erfährt auch gerade der
facebook konzern dem social media
giganten wird unter dem hashtag stop for
profit vorgeworfen nicht genug gegen
rassismus und hass zu tun
auch megan und harry unterstützen die
aktion inzwischen schließen sich immer
mehr unternehmen von adidas über north
face coca cola den werbe boykott gegen
facebook an
dieses jahr feiert voice of germany sein
zehnjähriges jubiläum allerdings nicht
mit rapper sido und alice merten für die
jubiläumsstaffel stehen bisher nur mark
foster und reggae fest jetzt kam raus
dass yvonne catterfeld und auch samu
haber zur show zurückkehren werden
und jetzt verraten wir dir exklusiv bei
place to be wer außerdem in der jury
2020 dabei ist es ist silbermond
sängerin stefanie kloß
sie war bereits 2016 für zwei jahre in
der jury und kommt jetzt zurück wir sind
gespannt auf ihr comeback
auch eine erfolgreiche sängerin aber
noch nicht in dem alter um in einer jury
zu sitzen ist blue ali carter mit gerade
einmal acht jahren tritt sie in die
fußstapfen ihrer eltern beyoncé und jay
sie und gewinnt ihren ersten bj mit dem
preis werden afro amerikanische künstler
und menschen aus minderheits gruppen
geehrt
luigi wurde für den song browns king
girl ausgezeichnet ein titel auf
beyoncés neuem album
[Musik]